le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
à la réunion 1379 assistantes
maternelles sont actuellement agréés
former l offre près de 4000 places pour
l'accueil des jeunes enfants
le département véritables acteurs et
partenaires a mis en place une série
dead pour que la famille fasse appel à
ses assistantes maternelles que faire
pour devenir assistante maternelle et
quels sont les dispositifs d aide en
faveur des familles on en parle tout de
suite dans lien social
l'assistante maternelle en complément
des parents à la responsabilité du
bien-être et de l'éducation des enfants
qui lui sont confiés pendant les temps
d'accueil
il ou elle doit être en capacité de
répondre aux besoins fondamentaux de
sécurité physique et affective des
enfants de contribuer à leur
développement harmonieux en tenant
compte des attentes de leurs parents en
matière d'éducation
chaque année près de 150 assistantes
maternelles bénéficient d'une formation
gratuite obligatoire qui est organisé et
prise en charge par le département afin
d'assister les familles à faire appel à
leurs services le conseil départemental
a également développé une série dead
dans le but de valoriser l'accueil chez
les assistants maternels
le shaq marmaille l'abaissement de l'âge
d'accueil et les aides à l'amélioration
de l'habitat
une application a également été mise en
place permettant aux assistantes
maternelles de se faire connaître et
aidant les parents dans leurs recherches
une tonne l'internet et aux éducatrices
dans la continuité de l'éducation et la
prise en charge de l'enfant par la
sécurité l'alimentation la crêperie le
social et les jeux d'éveil par l'enfant
apprend en jouant
il faut déjà aimé des enfants en ligne
et être respectueux des jouets aimé
travailler avec eux à des points filet
de ce métier
c'est
de s'adapter à l'enfant et non la gers
alors pour faire ce métier on fera une
demande auprès du conseil général afin
d'obtenir l'agrément mais d'abord de
responsables de la pmi ne viendra à
notre domicile voir si tout est dans les
normes
une fois l'agrément obtenu on peut
accueillir les enfants de 0 à 3 ans et
non du les accueille avec les banques
alors cet agrément permettra aux parents
de solliciter la caf pour un van ryn
être vivant tu es là alors pour les
personnes qui sont intéressées par les
relations fraternelles
il faut déjà au préalable assisté à une
information actionnariat quatre réunions
qui se tiennent par mois il faut
s'inscrire au préalable par téléphone
pour y assister alors si vous habitez
dans le nord et dans l'est
le numéro à composer ce 02 62 21 points
27 08
et si vous habitez dans le sucre dans
l'ouest c'est le 02 62 57 98 57
c'est une puéricultrice qui anime cette
réunion et vous pourriez obtenir toutes
les informations que vous souhaitez marc
avoir sur le métier d'assistante
maternelle elle va aborder entre autres
comment justement demandé un agrément
comme envoyer un dossier
comment se passe l'évaluation quelles
sont les décisions qui sont possibles au
terme de cette évaluation les conditions
de logement les compétences qui sont
nécessaires pour exercer ce métier
alors après la réunion donc si la
personne est toujours intéressé pour
exercer le métier il suffit d'envoyer
son dossier de manière complète de nos
esprits de la réunion et à ce moment là
une puéricultrice appellera la la
candidate à fond de quoi donner rendez
vous pour faire l'évaluation un
entretien vidéo il faut savoir que le
conseil d'état qui mental qu'on verse
une aide aux parents qui embauche une
assemblée dernière à gré posséder des
qualités d'écouté anticiper les besoins
de l'enfant puis à porter affection et
un sentiment de sécurité être disponible
et discrets sont indispensables pour
assurer la fonction d'assistante
maternelle
le site internet du département le
www.cglpl.fr permet aux assistantes
maternelles de se faire connaître et de
fournir des informations sur leur
disponibilité et leurs conditions
d'accueil pratique accessible partout
une application pour smartphones et
tablettes numériques a été développé par
le conseil départemental secteur
géographique critères de disponibilité
sont autant de critères permettant aux
familles de trouver leur assistante
maternelle et de la contacter
directement pour en savoir plus venez
assister à la journée départementale des
assistants maternels qui se déroulera le
samedi 28 novembre de 9 heures à 13
heures au palais de la source à
s'adonner le conseil départemental de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais